bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 1er octobre
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal on
commence au site avec les titres de
votre actualité locale visite à chatou
et à poissy pour l'ancien premier
ministre aujourd'hui candidat à la
primaire à droite alain juppé était dans
les yvelines hier lors du meeting qui
clôturait son déplacement il a appelé à
se débarrasser au plus vite du
gouvernement socialiste
depuis dix ans l'association du fun pour
tous intervient auprès des enfants en
situation de handicap mental
la structure basée notamment à
guyancourt propose un accueil spécialisé
sur les temps périscolaires et les
vacances
reportage et explications en plateau
avec bruno grosvalet fondateur de
l'association
enfin sports saint quentin en yvelines
face aux mureaux c'est la fiche de la
prochaine journée de promotion d'honneur
en rugby l'entraîneur de 50 ans sera
présent à la fin de cette édition et je
suis donc avec bruno grosvalet en
plateau avec nous merci d'avoir répondu
à notre invitation
nous parlerons dans quelques instants
des dix ans de votre association avant
cela revenons à notre actualité locale
l'ancien premier ministre et maire de
bordeaux alain juppé était donc en
déplacement mercredi soir dans les
yvelines un déplacement à la rencontre
des élus de chatou et de poissy pour
évoquer la démocratie de proximité
un déplacement qui s'est terminé par un
meeting face aux sympathisants et aux
militants il a forcément été question de
la primaire à droite à droite pardon
wilfried est riche et éolienne elle a un
pouvoir
conny perrin seule erreur est
aujourd'hui discrédité et dont il faut
se débarrasser le cnic possible du recul
matraquage fiscal réforme brouillonne
l'ancien premier ministre n'a pas fait
dans la demi-mesure mercredi soir à
poissy alain juppé accueillis par le
maire et conseiller départemental karl
olive et applaudi par les militants et
les sympathisants sous les regards des
ténors républicains des yvelines du
président du sénat gérard larcher à la
députée en campagne pour les régionales
valérie pécresse en passant par le
président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier un discours incisif pour
celui qui apparaît souvent dans les
sondages comme le plus à même de
remporter la primaire à droite l'année
prochaine il bénéficie en tout cas dans
les yvelines de nombreux soutiens j'ai
ici beaucoup d'amis parmi les élus bien
sûr parmi la population
je suis très heureux bien sûr de te
sentir ce mouvement d'adhésion
enfin la route est longue je vais
effectivement dans un instant raconte
rencontrer les responsables de les
comités locaux qui se met en place avec
une double mission d'abord animé le
débat pour l'instant autour de mon livre
sur l'éducation on a parlé à l'instant
de l'apprentissage vous à fait essentiel
et puis ensuite le moment venu pour
préparer bien sûr le vote aux primaires
c'est un homme qui est mûr pour ce genre
de responsabilité
les parcelles m'enfin je pense que c'est
peut-être même le plus sage je trouve
que c'est un homme surtout ouvert et
beaucoup de il ya aussi beaucoup
d'expérience et je pense que ces deux
qualités qui sont absolument nécessaires
ça devrait de son tour parce qu'il
arrive enfin en fin de circuit qui
pensent cela il faut retrancher ne soit
jamais produit
un peu plus tôt dans la journée le maire
de bordeaux a parlé démocratie
participative à poissy le conseil de
développement économique et social fêter
son premier anniversaire
la primaire à droite et au centre
devrait se dérouler les 20 et 27
novembre 2016
six candidats se sont déclarés et il
pourrait y en avoir encore un de plus
nicolas sarkozy n'a à ce jour rien
officialisé et vous avez peut-être déjà
eu la chance de goûter ses produits la
ferme de viltain située à jouy en josas
a agrandi sa laiterie construite en 1978
rénové en 2003 la laiterie est complété
d'un atelier de production de yaourts
si la ferme on produit déjà 200 mille
par an elle espère bientôt atteindre le
chiffre de 1 million la machine a permis
à la firme d'embaucher un nouveau
fromage et on écoute benoît dupré
agriculteurs fromager à la ferme de
viltain micro de mélanie poker on a la
chance d'être porté par
l'engouement de la clientèle pour les
produits locaux
donc on a des collectivités qui nous en
demande des grosses quantités
c'est pas seulement la clientèle de
détail à fur et à mesure qu'on va avoir
des clients mac on va savoir
bon on a une production qui est quand
même importante puisque cette machine
permet de produire 2000 yaourts à
l'heure donc on a de quoi faire
sachant qu'on est c'est un atelier qui
travaillent 39 heures par semaine une
belle initiative et qui perdure pour la
onzième année les élèves du centre
horticole d'enseignement et de promotion
situé au tremblay sur mauldre ont
récolté des pommes de terre au profit
des restos du coeur
le projet est réalisé par tous les
niveaux de l'établissement des
collégiens aux adultes en formation
courte
tout au long de la journée on écoute les
précisions de damien giraud professeur
d'aménagement au micro de camille
lambert et manon parle beaucoup des
valeurs de la république et densément
aussi agricole on a une déclinaison sur
les barres de république donc la
solidarité sans fait partie donc c'est
important de d'aider les gens les plus
démunis à pouvoir aussi manger à leur
faim
simplement il part du principe c'est une
bonne action dès qu'on parle des restos
du coeur
il n'y a pas de souci ils sont tous dans
une vision une attitude positive face à
cette opération
l'opération microdon reprend du service
la 7e édition de cette collecte de fonds
au profit des associations de solidarité
internationale se déroulera du 2 au 4
octobre une trentaine d'associations
subventionnées par le groupement
d'intérêt public yvelines coopération
internationale et développement seront
présentes dans différentes enseignes
pour présenter leurs actions
si vous souhaitez les aider c'est simple
il suffit d'acheter des cartes de dons
d'une valeur de 2 à 3 euros qu'elle vous
proposeront puis de présenter la carte à
code barres au moment de votre passage
en caisse
un geste simple qui a permis l'an
dernier de recueillir plus de 25000
euros fois je le rappelle nous sommes en
plateau avec bruno grosvalet fondateur
de l'association du fun pour tous située
à guyancourt
l'association fête ses 10 ans cette
année elle intervient auprès des enfants
et adolescents en situation d'handicap
mental en leur proposant des activités
périscolaires fanny bourdillon s'est
rendu mercredi après midi dans les
locaux de l'association assister à l'un
des ateliers proposés
regardez
l'association du fun pour tous fêtera
ses 10 ans ce vendredi
ouvert en 2005 à guyancourt ce centre
propose un accueil spécialisé pour
enfants et ados avec un handicap mental
pis ils roller vtt ou encore art
plastique de nombreuses activités leur
sont proposées sur les temps
périscolaires
aujourd'hui aminé lohan suivent un
atelier de pâtisserie
on travaille sur
les ingrédients pour les différencier
pouvoir travailler l'autonomie est
capable de faire des choses seul en
cuisine on travaille sur la motricité
fine mélangée casser les oeufs tous en
effet après le plaisir de pouvoir
proposer son gâteau goûter aux autres
d'antan disant qu'ils n'ont pas été de
tout repos pour l'équipe du fun pour
tous en 2013 le centre frôlé la faillite
avec un manque à gagner de 50 mille
euros aujourd'hui il se porte mieux
une situation qui permet de développer
de nouveaux projets
le projet c'est d'ouvrir en journée il
de devenir accueil temporaire pour des
enfants qui n'ont pas de prise en charge
et qui sont à la maison c'est quelque
chose qu'on fait déjà mais ils viennent
simplement sur les temps périscolaires
et vacances donc c'est pas suffisant
c'est à dire c'est des enfants qui ont
été déscolarisés qui sont en attente
d'une place en institution spécialisée
qui n'ont pas de place donc voilà ils
sont sans solution et sont chez eux
on n'a pas de financements suffisants
pour pouvoir ouvrir en journée en 2014
le centre a reçu 81 enfants venant de
tout le département pour seulement 30
place la liste d'attenté est longue
du fun pour tous espèrent ouvrir des
centres similaires dans le reste de la
région pour répondre aux demandes de
toutes les familles alors bruno vay
grosvalet dix ans d'existence pour une
association c'est déjà un beau parcours
qu'est ce qui a changé qu'est ce qui a
éveillé depuis vos débuts je suis passé
déjà de tout seul sur le terrain une
équipe de neuf salariés maintenant des
financements depuis cinq ans on a mal
traversé une crise majeure qui a permis
de sensibiliser les pouvoirs publics à
l'intérêt que pouvait avoir notre
association pour la prise en charge des
enfants en situation de handicap sur le
après écoles et après institutions
spécialisées et donc ça s'est pas fait
tout seul évidemment mais maintenant ça
y est ça commence à se stabiliser et on
commence à voir une écoute au niveau
public
donc voilà ça commence à être de mieux
en mieux on l'a vu donc dans le
reportage vous accueilli environ à 80
jeunes proposer plus d'activités
maintenant il ya un accompagnement
différents vous avez voilà a fini le
travail sur ces éléments alors sur le
fond non ça reste le même c'est à dire
que
sont pas des animateurs ce sont des
éducateurs spécialisés qui accueille et
accompagne les enfants on utilise les
loisirs comme outil pour continuer à les
aider à les accompagner sur des axes
similaire ce que font les institutions
spécialisées en fait on prend le relais
quand les institutions spécialisées
ferme nous on ouvre et on continue le
travail éducatif qui est mis en place
donc en fait les activités sont diverses
et variées comme tout centre de loisirs
en fait c'est juste un support pour nous
du coup les éducateurs s'adapte aussi
aux enfants selon les enfants que vous
avez chaque année ça change peut-être
oui il ya un turnover effectivement la
problématique de notre association c'est
qu'en fait il n'y a pas de profil type
dans les structures spécialisées ya des
profils types nous on en a pas donc on
peut avoir des enfants qui ont une
déficience légère des enfants qui ont
une déficience lourdes comme des enfants
autistes notamment et du coup ça demande
une adaptabilité assez importante pour
les éducateurs spécialisés mais c'est
complexe
on l'a vu dans le reportage vous avez
rencontré des difficultés financières
depuis 2013 ça va mieux comment ça s'est
passé comme vous avez réussi à gérer ce
problème de taille alors fin 2013 donc
on avait un trop au niveau de notre
budget c'est important parce que là la
construction financière de l'association
reste précaire on n'a pas de
financements pérennes en fait donc on
avait un trou assez important donc j'ai
vu la crise arriver donc j'ai demandé à
la présidente de l'époque de me
licencier
donc j'ai perdu mon poste pendant un an
et tout le personnel a été mis en
chômage partiel pendant trois mois avec
un service minimum pour la clé les
enfants quand même donc déjà ça permet
de faire des économies ensuite le préfet
a été saisi et ensuite on a demandé des
financements aux municipalités pour
lesquels on accueille les enfants qui ne
peuvent pas aller dans les centres de
loisirs classique
donc tout ça mis bout à bout ont fait
que la situation a pu se rétablir sur le
deuxième semestre 2014 est là pour 2015
ont commencé un petit peu à souffler
parce que vous avez des financements
dans des familles qu'ils mettent leurs
enfants dans votre association est aussi
de
municipalité ça alors les financements
c'est la caf des yvelines la casse qui
il y à la ddcs anciennement jeunesse et
sports il ya la préfecture des yvelines
aussi il ya la région ile de france et
donc quelques municipalités sur les 30
municipalités pour lesquels on accueille
des enfants il y en à peu près cinq ou
six qui ont répondu favorablement à des
demandes de financement en 2013 vous
vouliez être identifiées par la rs donc
l'agencé régionale de santé comme une
attitude médico éducatif où on est ce
projet ce que ça a évolué alors ça
évolue effectivement on en est pas
encore à la finalisation de ce statut en
tant que structures médico sociales
maintenant ce qui se profile pour nous
c'est de devenir accueil temporaire en
journée il ya une évaluation des besoins
qui est en train d'être réalisées auprès
de la rs et on pourrait rentrer
justement sur le futur appel à projet
qui va paraître sur ce créneau là en
fait parce que vous n'avez pas encore
d'agrément comme ça se fait que vous ne
l'avez pas justement
justement c'est une bonne question on
peut on pas dans les cases en fait notre
activité est atypique et c'est on
développe un nouveau secteur
en fait qui n'est pas référencé dans les
lignes budgétaires dans toutes les
institutions publiques quelles qu'elles
soient
vous pouvez expliquer rappelons pour
votre activité ici origines et intrigue
mais si spécifique par rapport justement
à ces enfants est ce qu'on est un peu
les seuls à proposer justement cette
forme d'accompagnement tout à fait de
cette façon là sont nées les seuls à le
faire effectivement on a même des
demandes qui viennent des départements
limitrophes
cette demande doit elle a été identifiée
moi quand j'étais éducateur spécialisé
il ya dix ans en institution et des
médico éducatif les équipes voilà tout
le monde faisait le constat qui avait
rien pour les enfants après l'ime ou
après l'école ou alors très peu
d'inclusion et du coup ça posait
vraiment problème aux familles qui
avaient voilà des contraintes au niveau
emploi du temps et qui de part déjà le
handicap de leur enfant avait une
complexité dans la gestion de l'emploi
du temps mais ça en rajouter du coup il
y avait vraiment besoin de créer quelque
chose de spécifique pour ces enfants
tout en mettant en place de l'infusion
collective ce que ce que l'on fait avec
la ville de guillon coin justement les
familles donc jusqu il se tourne vers
vous
vous avez 80 prennent en charge 80
enfants il ya une liste d'attenté et
vosges et on ne pouvait pas y accueillir
tant qu'association elle se retrouve et
bien non pas de mode de garde comme
toutes les autres familles
c'est à dire qu'elles sont obligées
d'être à leur domicile vers 16h 16h30
alors autour de l'enfant une fois que
l'institution spécialisée fermé et
pendant les vacances by a pas de
solution de garde donc d'effacer les
grands parents qui prennent le relais
des fois ci les mamans qui s'arrêtent de
travailler va sacrer d'autant plus de
complexité que l'encré déjà le handicap
c'est très lourd comme situation a
justement pour ces familles vous vous
occupez des enfants est ce que vous êtes
aussi là un peu pour les parents alors
on voit certains parents en direct qui
viennent chercher les enfants sur notre
lieu d'accueil à guyancourt donc ça ne
remet ça leur permet aussi à quelquefois
de d'avoir un lieu d'écouté aussi les
éducateurs sont là pour les écouter et
cdd dans la gestion du quotidien d'un
enfant en situation de handicap qui est
vraiment complexe
en plus de ça en novembre 2014 on a
ouvert un lieu d'accueil enfants parents
donc pour les plus petits pour les 0 5
ans donc c'est un soutien à la
parentalité en fait c'est basé sur les
maisons vertes de françoise dolto
donc c'est un accueil qui ouvert le
lundi matin et le jeudi matin sur notre
structure est lui en cours qui permet
pour ces familles de venir avec leurs
enfants en situation de handicap et
aussi des familles avec des enfants sans
handicap pour avoir un lieu d'écouté et
pour pour se poser à voir du soutien
pour voilà la parentalité notamment à
l'annonce du handicap vos projets un peu
pour l'avenir vous comptez voilà
accueillir plus d'enfants ça votre
objectif alors actuellement par rapport
aux locaux dans lesquels on est mise à
disposition gracieusement par la ville
de guyancourt on ne peut pas ce qui
serait intéressant c'est la partie de
mon aura cet agrément
enfin de la rs qui nous permettrait de
pérenniser dix années de travail
c'est d'avoir un bâtiment qui ne soit
propre et dédié pouvoir construit pour
nous c'est une projection je rêve un
petit peu mais pourquoi pas hélas oui ça
nous permettrait d'augmenter la capacité
d'accueil effective quelles sont les
démarches voilà aussi les jeunes ne
connaissent pas votre association pourra
vous confier un enfant est peut-être à
des réallocations l'association fun pour
tous alors nous appeler directement déjà
des lignes directes sur lesquels vous
pouvez nous joindre généralement c'est
les assistantes sociales les
établissements spécialisés qui oriente
les familles vers nous voilà ça se passe
a saisi aussi simplement et sur liste
d'attenté
il ya une fin elle est très longue allée
parce que c'est les enfants vous suivez
je pense mais d'année en année c'est ça
exactement on accueille des enfants des
fois je dois partir de l'âge de 6 ans
jusqu'à 18 ans oui il ya du
renouvellement mais il ya aussi des
enfants qui partent aussi donc on peut
toujours proposer de nouvelles places
mais à partir de là bas voyez par
exemple on arrive début octobre et elle
tous les groupes sont complets et donc
voilà on a à peu près une vingtaine de
familles qui en situation d'attenté pour
une prise en charge même heure mercredi
et par mois ou ou deux à trois journées
par vacances du coup les les familles
inscrivent leurs enfants pour une
journée puis en journée comment ça se
passe en retrait sur le fonctionnement
c'est comme un centre de loisirs
classique en fait donc il ya une
fréquence d'inscription tous les soirs
en semaine mercredi de mercredi enfin
c'est vraiment la carte et après je vais
vous quand les ados deviennent trop gros
ou les orienter vers d'autres d'autres
établissements il ya un relais alors
généralement quand ils arrivent à l'âge
adulte il s'orienter vers des structures
a dû tous et des foyers qui les prennent
en charge à temps complet dont qu'ils
ont plus besoin
très bien merci beaucoup bruno goval est
on le rappelle vous mettez vous disant
demain dans vos locaux afghans quoi donc
je vous souhaite davance voilà un joyeux
anniversaire
si vous souhaitez vous renseigner sur
l'association le site internet est le
suivant www.defense.gouv.fr il nous vous
en parlions mardi
aujourd'hui c'est la journée
internationale des personnes âgées
journée organisée sous l'égide de l'onu
un moment important pour l'association
les petits frères des pauvres
l'association a mis en place différentes
initiatives comme à plaisir ou à
l'hôpital de grignon de jeunes lycéens
ont rencontré des personnes âgées pour
une journée d'échangé intergénérationnel
autour de l'opération des fleurs de la
fraternité
sephora namani elodie moines
aujourd'hui jeudi 1er octobre est
célébrée la journée internationale des
personnes âgées l'association les petits
frères des pauvres se mobilisent à
l'hôpital de pédiatrie nyon pour lutter
contre l'isolément des personnes âgées
aux personnes âgées sont isolés que l'
isolement ça n'est pas simplement en
domicile à la maison c'est également des
personnes âgées en hébergement collectif
qui lorsqu on va les voir nous disent je
n'ai pas de visite
je vois des personnes qui viennent me
voir peut faire des soins pour s'occuper
de moi mais je n'ai personne qui vient
me voir tout moi et elles nous disent
vraiment voilà ça m'a changé ma vie les
petits frères des pauvres c'est ma
famille donc ce sont des choses là qui
sont vraiment précieuse pour nous pour
cette action spéciale et fleurs de la
fraternité des lycéens étaient invités à
partager cette journée avec les
résidents de l'hôpital chansons dans ses
remises de runs pour cette belle
rencontre intergénérationnelle pour le
tout les résidences apporte de la joie
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui n'ont
pas dit qu'ils ont plus de familles qui
partent plus en vacances qui qui reste
tout le temps dans l'es6 avis je pense
apporter le sourire aux personnes âgées
la joie est
j'aime apprendre de nouvelles
expériences des choses qu'il a vécues
que moi je n'ai pas encore vécu parce
que vous êtes encore jeune nouvelle
rencontre intergénérationnelle le 16
décembre prochain où les résidants de
l'hôpital sont attendus au lycée
sonia-delaunay de villepreux pour fêter
noël et comme chaque jeudi nous passons
au sport et au rendez vous sportifs du
week-end qui ne faudra pas manquer avec
notre journaliste sportif est nickel
elle est mis dos rond soir à michael
moore florane alors le week end était
très sportif la semaine dernière avec la
course à pied vous en souvenez à la
course à pied paris versailles mais
également la coupe de france de football
mais rassurez-vous il le sera tout
autant pour ce premier week-end
d'octobre y aura notamment match qu'il
ne faudra pas manquer ce week-end ce
sera du rugby c'est la rencontre entre
saint quentin en yvelines et les mureaux
en promotion 2 heures dimanche à 15
heures au stade du bout des clous à
maurepas
vous l'aurez compris floral c'est un
derby yvin mois pour nous parler de ce
rendez-vous nous recevons le coach du
sky rugby thomas payen bonsoir
alors vous venez d'enchaîner deux
victoires en deux matches
en promotion d'honneur est ce qu'on peut
dire vous êtes dans une forme optimale
on a très bien commencé la saison c'est
vrai qu'on deux équipes qui ont
l'habitude de jeu le milieu de deux
classements en promotion d'honneur
donc on est vraiment ravi en plus ces
deux matches à l'extérieur donc de cette
performance maintenant c'est vrai qu'il
ya un gros match ce week-end compte
triel qui est une grosse équipe de la
poule donc maintenant à nous de relever
le défi et surtout sur notre premier
match à domicile
vous avez une équipe très joueuse et
très offensifs cette année oui tout à
fait on a une équipe jeune de jeunes
issus du club de la formation de saint
quentin en yvelines et jeu qu'on essaye
de mettre en place en effet ce un jeu de
mouvement aéré où le ballon bouge
beaucoup et on essaie de déstabiliser la
défense
grâce à ce jeu offensif ce match contre
trier les mureaux est ce qu'il est très
important pour la suite de la saison
ou est ce que c'est un match on va dire
que vous prenez pas forcément au sérieux
tout de suite dans certains matchs et
ils vont en baver tous les matches
vraiment cette année pour pascal rugby
notre objectif c'est la montée en
honneur la montée il ya que 2 et club
qui monte en honneur donc nous on a
vraiment ciblé ce match commun comme un
gros match on avait notre bloc deux
premiers matchs de trois matchs notre
objectif c'est de sortir invaincue de
ces matchs donc
donc on n'a pas droit à l'erreur ce week
end les quelles sont les forces de trier
numéro treize numéros c'est un club qui
a l'habitude de jouer à ce niveau là
dedans le haut de classement de
promotion d'honneur avec des joueurs
d'expérience c'est des joueurs assez
accrocheur qui lâcheront rien jusqu'au
bout donc à nous opposer à ça à notre
jeunesse notre notre vitesse et de
d'aller chercher la victoire est la
victoire vous y croyez ah oui j'en doute
pas et quels sont les objectifs du club
cette année ça sera de monter c'est la
montée en honneur
quoi qu'il arrive à 2 oui c'est la
montée en honneur c'est vraiment
l'objectif fixe et on veut mettre tous
les moyens pour y arriver et vous avez
l'effectif pour réussir cette montée en
honneur
oui on a étoffé notre effectif cette
année avec beaucoup de jeunes du club
des juniors qui sont montés qui sont
directs très compétitif donc on s'appuie
dessus pour nos résultats et on espère
arriver à monter en honneur avec un
effectif plus complet que la saison
dernière et est ce que vous sentez que
vous faites partie peut-être des favoris
de cette poule
oui je pense que on est favoris on est
au fait partie des favoris avec avec le
chien également triel qui est une bonne
équipe pour la montée en honneur
on est perçu comme ça en tout cas chaque
année vous êtes si proche de la de la
montée cette année c'est la bonne
j'espère mais on y croit tous en tout
cas l'objectif du club était vraiment
soit l'année dernière soit cette année
de monter donc vraiment on va tout
mettre en tout mettre en oeuvre pour y
arriver
et est ce qu'un joueur sur lesquels peut
être vous allez vous appuyer cette année
tu vois où c'est le collectif qui
passait vraiment le collectif notre
vision du jeu qui est un gain
jeu de mouvement où tout le monde trouve
sa place dedans donc il n'y a pas un
joueur en particulier même si on attend
beaucoup de nos leaders de jeu merci à
vous d'être passé sur ce coup là dessus
je le rappelle donc le match contre les
murs est programmée ce dimanche à 15
heures au hameau repart et au stade du
bout des clous et toujours en rugby à
mikel on jouera également en fédérale 3
ce week end
effectivement floral on jouera en
fédérale 3 verset y aura l'occasion de
se rattraper de son début de saison
difficile ils recevront metz dimanche
prochain à 15 heures donc pour le compte
de la 3e journée du championnat
la victoire devrait être jouable pour
les versaillais mais cet avant dernier
du classement a déjà encaissé 88 points
en deux matches ça devrait être une
formalité pour versailles et vous
l'aurez compris j'ai pris et je suis
restée avec attention il ya aussi de la
course à pied il me semble c'est ça le
très urbain de monter vos tournées
programmées ce dimanche à partir de 9h30
au départ du centre sportif pierre de
coubertin la course traverse huit
quartiers de la commune pour un parcours
total de 13 km il sera également semé
d'embûches les 250 coureurs déjà
inscrits pourront tester leurs chevilles
leur endurance sur la route dans des
chemins ils monteront également des
escaliers vous l'aurez compris floral ce
sera très physique il y aura également
des courses pour les enfants et pour les
personnes handicapées à partir de 11h30
si les téléspectateurs qui nous écoutent
veulent s'inscrire il reste des places
où on peut prendre son dossard 15
minutes avant le début des épreuves ça
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour les
retardataires il ya aussi la du basket
basket pour terminer cette chronique
sport trap euros soit vitry châtillon
viry-châtillon ce samedi à 20 heures au
gymnase paul mallet un match que les
trappistes doivent remporter pour
effacer la défaite du week-end dernier
contre marly le roi il avait perdu je
vous le rappelle florane 81 à 64 à
l'extérieur pour ce premier match de la
saison à domicile les trappistes compte
sur le soutien du public pour avoir
remporté la victoire mais également sur
leur pivot de 2 mettront ce jouet
casseus de m onde émettront oui c'est
vrai qu'on l'avait reçu en plateau à
fait impressionnant
merci aux week-ends y aussi un autre
match à ne pas rater dimanche soir au
clasico le clasico bien sûr que j'avais
un petit pronostic
malheureusement je pense que ça va être
très compliqué pour pour l'om
sur ce match là je pense que le paris
saint germain va l'emporter très bien
émis en suisse avec attention je pense
aussi que le paris saint germain va
l'emporter dans de très bonnes
dispositions
merci beaucoup michael on vous retrouve
dès lundi
prochain à 18h30 dans le 7-8 sport pour
un débrief complet de ces rendez vous
fin enfin vous les transformez ou
aménager votre jardin cet événement
regardé le vous donnera peut-être
quelques idées un concours paysagiste
est programmé jusqu'à ce dimanche au
jardin de la vallée à magny les hameaux
5école yvelinoise à la main verte et à
l'esprit créatif vont s'opposer pour
remporter la compétition un reportage de
mickaël millero et patrick jacques de
dixmude cinq écoles un objectif
remporter la quatrième édition du
concours dialogue au jardin organisée
jusqu'à ce dimanche au jardin de la
vallée à magny-les-hameaux
comme chaque année la compétition oppose
les meilleurs apprentis paysagistes des
yvelines
pour cette édition 2015 les étudiants
doivent imaginer le jardin de demain à
cette occasion les visiteurs vont
s'improviser jury du concours élire
leurs scènes préférées
c'est eux qui vont élire la scène jardin
de demain parmi les quatre scènes des
élèves
nous allons du coup leur apporter notre
jugement aussi c'est aussi l'heure leur
montrer que il ya il ya aussi
différentes facettes
vous avez bien fait votre travail sur
les différentes étapes qu'est-ce qui est
améliorée c'est aussi les points à
améliorer qu'on peut apporter et les
élèves ont aussi voté pour les autres
scènes de jardin donc il n'y auront pas
droit de voter pour leurs scènes donc de
chaque école à droite choisir la chaîne
de jardin qui correspond et c'est aussi
se juger et apporter si sa critique et
absorber la critique aussi le lot parmi
les écoles sélectionnées on retrouve
notamment le cfa de saint germain les
l'école tecomah de jouy en josas pour
les professeurs de ces structures
l'objectif de ce concours est avant tout
pédagogique
c'est un peu un travaillant en amont de
ce qui les attend dans la profession ce
qui est intéressant dans cette idée là
de ce puits central aménagé sais c'est
qu'ils ont travaillé ce projet l'a22 a
jusqu'à z est donc lié toute une
dynamique d'une place d'une vingtaine
d'élèves autour de ce projet là
je crois plus david à mettre un escalier
qu'est ce qui vous empêche de faire des
essais un ace qui pour monter des très
enthousiaste projet pas forcément dans
le but de gagner mais de concourir à
tout simplement plus de huit cents
curieux sont attendus à magny les
hameaux pour découvrir le travail des
apprentis paysagiste le vainqueur de la
compétition sera désigné lundi soir
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis demain
vous retrouver wilfrid richy pour le 7 8
le journal et on vous retrouve également
un devant un michael pour le 7-8 week
end question cinéma avec les yeux d'elsa
de saint cyr l'école mais également
sport comme d'habitude comme d'habitude
eh bien nous le suivons avec attention
également pour ma part je vous retrouver
lundi à 18 heures pour une nouvelle
édition du journal en direct je vous
souhaite donc une excellente soirée et
un très bon week-end